let's watch this clip from a comedian
you might have heard of by the name of
Chris Rock okay
volume please production and me
okay I'm gonna play
only women children and dogs
are loved unconditionally a man is only
love under the condition that he
provides
okay when you meet a new girl what do
your friends ask what she look like
ladies when you meet a new guy
what do your friends ask you what does
he do
what the [ __ ] does that do that can help
you out
this [ __ ] facilitate a dream or
not only that is so true oh it's so so
true I mean as they say men have to
become women can just be it's so so true
um you know it's why
um you know men are shipped off to war
um it's why the women and the children
are protected first I think Society
despite you know what feminists say I
think Society
um
values women and children inherently
um and not men men are disposable to
society 100 the Titanic's thinking women
and children on the rafts and then men
you know good luck out there buddy hope
you can swim Leo yeah they're completely
accurate yeah
no is this accurate or not it's
absolutely accurate and I I'm okay with
it like the world is sexist you know
there's going to be times where I'm
gonna be sexually objectified and then
men are going to be reduced to their
wallets that's just what it is to walk
in this world as a man or a woman but I
mean I think I'm more okay being cut
throat about it because I'm willing to
do what it takes to make a provider
comfortable in providing for me to make
him feel like I'm grateful for him I
mean I don't know no matter what it
takes but it's hard to stay in love with
a broke man have you tried have you
tried if you got to go to the food
pantry you resentful and this is why we
do the sauce cast on value tables and
Gentlemen people say why do you talk so
much about dating and relationships you
think money just lives in a [ __ ]
vacuum yeah okay it goes hand in hand
with relationship you can't even buy me
Ramen I'm supposed to love you get out
I'm sorry okay she's about to get worked
up right now
Sarah you must have some strong feelings
on this give me something girl when
Chris Rock says this is he accurate or
no yeah no I think the pressure on men
is like a lot absolutely but I agree
with her like you become more feminine
when they when they do that role for you
but but I mean like for all that
pressure to be put on them and they're
worth no I I think that's probably hard
listen uh
women are judged on their beauty yeah
and I'm going to be very clear with my
words here that's external beauty and
internal beauty that's okay that's
correct now it's not just the looks
believe me I've grown up in Miami South
Beach there's super models that I hung
out with or I'm like you are very ugly
on the inside okay and there's nice
sweet girls where I'm like you are
adorable inside and out and there's a
major difference okay
um men yes you know look good feel good
work out whatever
but money and status and income and
wealth and all that is Paramount to a
man in a relationship okay because you
can show me the hottest dude in the
world I asked us I love asking these
questions to women this is like one of
the first questions I ever did when we
started the show and I had asked these
questions to all the girls I know in
South Beach A or B answer don't give me
some [ __ ] as well can this guy no
you can either be with a hot ass dude
who's broke and lives with his parents
broke
can't keep a job hurting hot though okay
or a rich ass dude life is good you
don't have to do [ __ ] life is great
you're driving whatever car house shop
whatever
but he's gross like he's not good
looking it's kind of kind of sloppy
who you picking
and I watch women's mind melt and
they're like but like can the can the
good looking guy have money no
rich and sloppy
good looking and broke no I'm picking
either no so this is what women try to
do nobody
I'm just trying to think for the sake of
this conversation pick one I'm trying to
think like do I care about the bedroom
do I care about my Offspring I feel like
I probably care about the bedroom so I
guess I'll go for the hot guy but I'm
just shallow I guess I don't know okay
well I appreciate the honesty by the way
you're married to Ted oh no Tom you're
married to Tom yeah so you're still
married to Tom this is a hypothetical it
ain't true no yeah Leia go
I have no idea pick one layer they both
sound terrible I know that's why we're
asking six pack or six figures what you
got okay because they both sound
terrible I'll take the six pack
okay Sarah you're living in love with
them both no no you don't love them but
there's no love involved what listens
everything they can't just give an
answer
if you want to throw up what makes you
want to throw up and the other one
you're throwing up in a palace right the
other gets you wet but you're at his
parents house so if there's no love
involved then it's the same amount of
emotion for both right yeah it's an
obvious that you would go for the wealth
if you're just
ladies and gentlemen there's no love
involved yeah give it like one mates you
want to throw up and then the other one
makes you just like throwing up in a
Rolls-Royce I'm sorry yeah who's your
pick that's a hard one
um
I would pick
it's just cringy to think about I would
pick
can I skip this no you have to answer
um so rich gross guy or uh I can't
believe we have to ask the question
again this is what the guys
at home uh yes
think about who you've picked in the
past like we've all probably done it you
know what I mean I mean I've dated a
broke eye but like because I was [ __ ]
horrible like that was traumatizing
who's your pick young lady because he
was broken because he was just a piece
of [ __ ]
um I think both
um
I would pick
my heart's raising I don't know I would
pick maybe just pick the six pack
I would pick the six pack and then try
and get him to yeah
I would pick the old man if he's like
about to die
I'm gonna find me a real one by the way
exactly I like you gentlemen so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]